キラリーン
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです(ﾄﾞﾔ)
みなさんダーツ知ってますか
HA☆HA☆HA
まあダーツって聞くとなんかこう夜の遊びみたいな雰囲気が
あるんですが、ダーツは誰でも楽しめる簡単なゲーム
ダーツができるものさえあればどこでも誰でも
ダーツが楽しむことができます(ﾆｺ)
ダーツって簡単、矢を準備し的に向かって
投げるだけ、投げた場所によって得点が変わって
得点を競ったり一つの数字に向かったり
ルールは様々さ、そんな楽しいダーツゲームなんですけど
僕はあることに気づいてしまいました。ご覧ください
ダーツの的ってめちゃくちゃ穴だらけじゃね？私は思ってしまいました。
というわけでここにできるだけダーツの矢集めてみました。
ダーツするお店よりたくさんあると思います。
あの
みたことないんすよ！ダーツをこう三つくらい投げて
抜いて、次の人がまたやるんでダーツの的にたくさん矢が
刺さったとこみたことないんすよ。逆になんで
三本抜くのかなと僕思いまして。ダースの矢が
たくさんあったら抜く必要ないんじゃね？ていうか抜く時間
勿体無いと思って。ダーツの矢を抜かなかったらどんなことが起きるのか
そしてダーツの的がどんな感じになるのかなっていうのを
知りたいので今日はダーツの的が限界になるまで
ダーツを投げてみようと思います。わかんないです。ちょっと考えられるパターン
重さで的がﾄﾞｽﾝと落ちるか
投げても投げても
矢が刺さらない。あの穴に入るスペースがなくなるか
他の何かが起きるか
ちょっといろんなことが考えられるんですけども
でもなんか綺麗だから刺さりまくって
的がお花みたいな感じに
なると思うんで。どうなるかわからないですけどやってみるよ
ほんとそれだけです。すいません。ほんとやってみたいだけなんです(泣)
グッドラック、はじめ
サンキュー、ピーポー
なんて言ってるかわかんない…
おおおお！ダブル x 3
わっ
おっ
お、20点のトリプルだ
20のトリプル！English, English
え、ここ…
え、English..
え、これ20のトリプルですよね？
うん
Fantastic Baby
3, 2, 1 GO!
WOW!
オーケー
んんー
オォー
イェア！
え！15トリプル！？
イェアー！
45点！
あ違う
フォーティーファイブ！
Wao！Hay！Go！Go！Go！Hay↓
うわ、やべ。はじかれるようになってきた。早くももういっぱいかもしれないな、これ
GO! x 4
待って…w
わかんなw　全然…トゥウェンティーですよね多分
Go　Go　ハイ！
ハジカレール
もう点数とかいいです！とりあえずいっぱいにします
Go！
待ってくださいよ
ドアニアナガアイタトキワ
ベンショウシマショウ
オオヤサンゴメンナサイ
WOW...
待って…
うわあああああああああああ！
待って、やばい
ああだめだ。これはマジでダメなやつだ
ここまでくるとさすがに刺さらなくなってくるな
すげえw
落ちたwww
すごいですw
落ちたらダーツでたちます！